[Music]
don't tell me you haven't imagined doing
this sitting behind this desk occupying
the most powerful seat in the
world I've done it and even when you're
playing the role of the president of the
United States you get a sense of the
awesome power we entrust to one
person the fate of our
nation sometimes that of the entire
world rest on that person's
shoulders but sometimes we disagree with
the person at the Top If We Had real
democracy we wouldn't have to protest we
want more control of our own
Destinies does society work best when
organized around a strong
leader or is there
another better
way what makes a good leader now he's
the chief of the
community you have to convince people
who may disagree to go along with you
how do we escape from Bad leaders women
started coming to me because the
government are not doing anything or the
tyranny of the m i was beaten on the
street
it was like first time I completely
understood who you really are if you're
a gay in
Russia and is democracy really the best
way to run Society Washington do like to
say this lobbying is briber everyone's
biased so everybody actually having to
go to make laws would be pretty
crazy this is my
journey to discover the ties that bind
us and the common Humanity inside
us this is destroy of
us societ is made up of individuals like
you and
me each one of us living Our Lives
chasing our own hopes and dreams but
it's not everyone for
[Music]
themselves we return to leaders to help
us work together enforce the rule of law
and protect us from harm we give up some
of our individual freedom for the sake
of the common good it's a social
contract we've been making for thousands
of
years I'm heading into the jungles of
Panama to witness this social contract
in the
making today an indigenous people known
as the um will hold their traditional
ceremony to select a new
[Music]
Chief you can see they like to play
soccer
or Nelson who learned English at a
school in Panama City is taking me to
the 's equivalent of Capitol Hill this
is the local house we use this for
meeting or for T what we would call
Lodge yes yeah once every four years
dozens of villagers Gather in this large
to choose their new
leader
today we are looking for another person
to be that we call El El El no is the
chief of the community okay so right now
we have two people in front that's two
person candidate the people like the
nominee yes the only requirements to run
for office or that you have to be over
30 and have a calm demeanor you see all
the people are going to make a line so
longer lines is the winner ah okay so
we're going to see right now who's going
to be El that's pretty
straightforward there's no secrecy no no
secret who votes for who and who you
[Music]
want the winner is him now he's the
chief of the community
okay the election is simple and
transparent there's no mudslinging no
hard feelings on the losing side in fact
the runnerup serves as a kind of vice
[Music]
president and everyone joins the Victory
celebration now what do you have to do
as
chief
the person that going to be the chief to
be very responsible and I don't know how
to say Pati passion yes
sweet feeling for yes for the village
yes I bought for him I can see that he's
a smart man and of course he's my father
inw got
[Music]
it
this is incredible to see something like
this true democracy in action of course
the imar need to work together to
survive so it's necessary for one person
to coordinate the group to get things
done that's why they entrust power to
the chief this kind of Corporation has
helped human societies flourish all
around the world it's a reminder of
what's at the core of our own political
system how simple it could
be most modern societies are
exponentially larger than the empor
village leaders are now expected to
protect millions of people in the nation
state now it is time time to take long
as strives let us then move forward
together I want to know what the weight
of that much responsibility feels
like I've come to New York City to meet
someone who was leader of the Free World
for eight years President Bill
Clinton we as a society have this
amazing rule of law and democracy why do
you think it came out so
strong well I think it it came as a
reaction
to popular dissatisfaction with
monarchies the idea that everybody could
have their say that people ought to be
in effect self-governing they ought to
pick
Representatives it really caught
hold it was this idea that sparked the
American
Revolution but representation doesn't
mean slavishly following the will of the
majority wait they wait they've had
their say the PCT between elected
officials and the people they represent
is much more complex there's 330 million
plus people in this country you can't
have a referendum on every decision you
can represent the will of your voters by
trying to carry out what you pledge to
do in the election but even there you
have to convince other people that may
disagree to go along with you then you
have to deal with things that were never
discussed in the
election both emergencies and things
that you know about that are going to
have a huge effect 5 10 15 20 years down
the road and so a lot of this will of
the people involves having the people
believe that you're at least keeping
them informed you're telling them what
the deal is and if you do something that
seems to to be unpopular you explain why
give me an example of two of the really
roughest decisions as our leader you had
to
make I remember when
um Mexico was about to go under in
1995 and like economic said they got 24
hours to live and then their currency
will come crashing down and you'll be
flooded with
immigrants it was going to be a disaster
and we don't help them but the American
people were like 80% against doing
anything because they said oh they're
got themselves in trouble so I had the
executive authority to do it and I did
it and everybody said oh this is
terrible they'll never pay the money
back we're going to be ripped off we're
being taken advantage of all Mexico paid
the loan back 3 years early with more
than $500 million in
interest economic decisions may impact
hundreds of millions of
lives but no choice is harder for a
leader to make than sending their own
citizens off to
war if you have to use
Force you put the lives of Young
Americans at risk so you need to be darn
sure you're doing the right thing before
you go around killing people because
they're consequences of that people
didn't want me to send so in to throw a
military dictator out in Haiti turned
out no one was killed mhm majority of
the people were against my trying to end
the slaughter in Bosnia but there were
250,000 dead people and 2 and a half
million refugees the risks from inaction
to the world would be far greater than
action people didn't want me to go into
Kosovo
but I didn't want turned into
Bosnia and they're still holding on to
their
democracy none of those places worked
out what you'd call
perfectly but we gave him a chance the
only thing that really matters is
whether do you leave things better than
you
started uneasy lies the head that wears
the crown what shakespare road of Kings
Still applies to our elected leaders
today President Clinton decided to make
a risky loan to
Mexico he put the lives of American
soldiers at risk to prevent genocide in
Kosovo these decisions were not driven
by a desire to be
popular but for the long range common
good that's what good leaders
do but around the
globe a wave of populist leaders is
coming to power their quest for
popularity May unleash mob
mentality and persecution of the
minority you kill us we kill your
[Applause]
country in the late
1960s the Castro in San
Francisco became a mecca for the gay
community people came here to enjoy the
social contra fact that heterosexuals
took for granted contribute to society
harm no one and the government will stay
out of your Private
Affairs well since then attitudes and
laws have changed at least here in
America but there are still places
around the world where simply being the
person you are harming no one is a
crime in 2013 13 Russia passed a law
Banning so-called gay
propaganda activists
say it triggered a jump in
discrimination and
violence against the LGBT
community I'm on my way to meet a
Russian immigrant couple Ole Dov and
Demetrius Stan
in Russia Oleg was a television host and
Dimitri was a successful
psychologist I want to know why they
left behind their careers to come to the
US so now you're a high-profile person
you got a TV show going on yeah when did
you publicly come out it was in
2013 yeah I came out on Facebook I can
show you that post today and for me is a
time to be brave openly and honestly I
want to tell you that I am gay
orientation is not a determining factor
in my attitude to life and people well
said World
changed because I was on my work I
posted on Facebook and I just went to to
the
hall and you know people just you know
was like a like I don't know yeah and
people didn't say hello to me didn't
smile to me I was like invisible person
and so after that it was like 2 weeks my
contract just was not renewed not
renewed yeah and I
felt how dangerous is it we have threats
it was Nightmare you you know it's many
messages Facebook text that story this
story were overwhelmed it wasn't
dangerous I know we cannot hide our body
language and maybe sometimes my body
Express who am I and I was uh beaten on
the
street it was terrible experience
because police did nothing so I I went
to the hospital because I
you know my my love in the hospital and
they just asked me who are you you can't
be here what are you do are your family
or what and I I just needed to lie
something like I I'm his boss or
something it was like first time I
completely
understood who you really are if you're
a gay in
Russia OLG and Demitri didn't feel safe
at home
anymore
so they went to New York to let the
storm from oleg's post blow over yeah
actually we seated for 7 days just an
apartment in New York yeah we just need
some time
to get away from everything
yeah OLG and Dimitri eventually went out
and explored the city the openness and
tolerance they discovered inspired them
seeing how life could be they refused to
accept their loss of Rights in Russian
Society instead they asserted them by
getting married in the
US after our marriage after our ceremony
somebody stole our pictures from
Facebook and published these pictures in
the
newspaper the article say to be gay is
it's a shame he's abnormal we need to
kill them so they need to kill
us uh it was really
terrifying that was a reason why we
stayed here yeah you only have each
other to hold on to
here it was difficult
choice we had our careers in
Russia we had all our friends and
families there yeah but here we can you
know to to go walk walk yeah yeah and
it's okay it's
normal I can tell people yeah it's my
husband so now you're happy and you feel
safe
yes here in the
US once the shift started change came
rapidly what do you think it would take
for Russia to be more relaxed about 100
years 200 years
unfortunately situation is getting worse
there is a lot of stereotypes in Russia
Russia has a different history and a
different Human Rights Movement they
need more strengths to overcome these
barriers toward
tolerance well I wish you both long life
happiness thank
you more than two centuries ago the
United States Constitution gave its
people certain
rights and among them was freedom of
expression America would be a new type
of society one where people would be
free to be who they really
are the LGBT community had to fight for
those same freedoms until
recently now Ole and Dimitri have
engaged in a struggle to move Russian
Society
forward I hope they succeed because in
the end any society that stops people
from being who they truly
are is bound to
[Music]
fall there will always be divisions in
this Society disagreements between
political religious and cultural groups
When leaders exploit these divisions
they can steal power from the
people and keep it all for
themselves in
1971 General edain took control of
Uganda with the military coup I must
make sure that every ugandans get a
fruit of
Independence he inherited a country
hungry for a strong native born leader
after decades of subjugation under
British
rule Amin was initially greeted with
cheers but his regime soon became one of
torture and
murder he earned the nickname The
Butcher of
[Music]
Uganda to try to understand how power
can descend into
tyranny I have come to Africa to meet
with someone who spent years in our
mean's inner Circ
uganda's former minister of Health Henry
cha I mean had eight
years in those eight years of
murders killings
eliminations how many people it was a
difficult figure to come by
150,000 half a million we will never
know
do you know why I mean did these things
as time went on power was getting
sweeter and sweeter by the day it always
were wanted and he he thought he could
carry on it seems that the longer he was
in power M the more violent he got a me
knew that he came into Power by the gun
and he used to tell his soldiers that
the gun is your sister is your mother
use it to get whatever you want many
innocent people were killed they were
thrown on the
lake in the Lake
Victoria and they ended up going onto
the
river and you'd find dead bodies
floating on the
river well this sounds like there was
just no law they're using prisoners to
beat their fellow prisoners to death not
knowing that the others will come and do
the same to
them it is the kind of brutality you
can't explain they you detain to commit
these atrocities yes I was advised in
fact that my own brother was also killed
in that way what was your reaction to
your brother's
death it's not um
something nice talk
about
[Music]
the social contract between a country's
leader and its citizens is based on
trust the
solution must be determined by the
people themselves the leader protects
the citizens in exchange for the power
to make decisions that affect
everyone but a dictator betrays this
trust and is only out for himself
ID Amin robbed hundreds of thousands of
ugandans of their lives in his mad quest
to hold on to
power the government of Africa this
strengthen thank you very much when Ain
began targeting members of his own
government Henri chamba started to fear
for his
life what would you do to them you will
see
after the murder of two cabinet
ministers who are friends of mine
someone sent me a
[Music]
note UV
s335 sl6 what is that those are the
numbers of security
cars used by
Yamin
in his execution
missions someone left a note saying that
he had heard some security voice in that
car talking about me being the next
victim for
execution I felt it was time to
go cha managed to resist the Temptations
to flee immediately
he waited for an official government
trip to the UN in Geneva and from there
found asylum in
London you went to work after that to
spread the word about him I decided to
fight Amin in a way that he could never
fight me with a gun I said I would use a
pen I gave interviews to senior
journalists about what a was doing to
the country I also worked on the book
the state of
blood for them to know what was
happening in our country Henry's writing
was crucial in spreading word of idia
means tyranny around the
world am mean's ever increasing lust for
power led him to invade neighboring
Tanzania foreign powers began to take
action that means our and cleared grip
began to loosen what is actually
happening in Uganda now troops are
deserting the Army and I mean is in
hiding on April 11th
1979 Ed Amin was overthrown by Ugandan
Rebels and Tanzanian
forces what do you think kept him in
power for so long I mean was very un
predictable he would do things that you
think were absolutely normal and yet in
the next minute he's doing the exact
opposite and that kept him in power
beyond what one would have expected
brutality and
unpredictability go
together the English historian Lord
Acton famously said power tends to
corrupt absolute power corrupts
absolutely few leaders have lived out
that phrase more vividly than Ed I mean
once he receives power there was no
moral line he wouldn't cross to keep
power the Spectre of amine is still with
us around the globe strong men still
covered power will do anything to get it
and anything to keep
it we must be ever Vigilant against
leaders who want power for
themselves not for us the
people when people are robbed of their
power when they lack a voice in their
own
fate they face a
choice accept it
or fight
[Applause]
back but in the rural lowlands of
Northern Kenya one group has found a
third way they are walking away and
building a new
[Music]
[Applause]
Society political science Professor
Faith ogeto OA is traveling from the
capital Nairobi to learn
[Music]
more
welcome thank you very much a pleasure
to be
[Music]
here the village is called umoja and its
founder is Rebecca
[Music]
[Applause]
lolos she and the other women here have
created a society with without
[Applause]
menca tell me a little bit about the
village and about the women that live
here yeah we have 48 women in this
Village we have new women coming the way
now you see the women are making the
houses the women who have come here
belong to Kenya's samburu tribe a
society where men hold all the power in
samburu culture most women can't own
property they themselves are considered
the property of
men in our community women has no right
we are not educated they didn't go to
school they don't have jobs they don't
own livestock so they have nothing to
live
on you know there someu people we are
polygamist and maybe you will start
disliking you the first wife and start
beating you until he start kicking you
out of that home if you don't also give
children then you are useless you'll be
isolated nobody wants
you so all the women that have come here
really have very difficult
stories they have been beaten they have
been threatened to be killed they have
beened Rebecca herself was abused and
evicted from her
home that's when she left to found
umoja we started umoja in
1990 decided to build the village so
that we can stay together and live
together when the men started seeing
toting success now they wanted to kill
me they said if we kill her then
everything will go down the men come and
beat the women they robbed the women
they wanted to KI us out of this land
even my own mom told me stop and I was
telling her I'm not going to stop how
did you protect yourselves we didn't
have any protection at night when we see
them we wake up we start running but we
refused to go out of this land
completely once we have already built
and we stayed here we live here it was
hard for them to get us out of this
land the women of umoja endured the
attacks and the raids on their Village
finally stopped umoja has now become a
thriving
[Music]
Community the women generate income by
making bead jewelry and selling them to
tourists they raise livestock and are
experimenting with growing their own
crops but umo's Crown
Jewel is its
School
2 1 2
this is where the women are creating a
new
society different from the one in which
they were
raised they hope the boys growing up
here will learn to treat women as equals
and take that attitude with them when
they leave the village as
adults we have seen education is the key
for
[Music]
every this Village is like a training
center with teach our boys to respect
the rights of the women we are proud of
our
sons if Rebecca has her way umoja is
just the beginning of a new broader
culture where women have a say you
always move forward I'm always moving
forward whether they say they are
killing me I'm not scared I'm always
going forward so our life is always
improving
the women of umoja were born into a
society where they had absolutely no
power where the men treated them like
cattle so they built a new
Society they are rewriting the social
contract giving women a voice in the New
Order and imbuing their sons with the
belief in gender
equality theirs is a young culture but
the future looks bright
new societies begin with the hope of
solving old problems ethics and
Corruption concerns at the center of a
federal bribery
investigation but human nature means
that certain challenges arise again and
again like the influence of
money can it be stopped from eroding the
very Foundation of democracy today's
hearing is about more than greed it's
simply a tale of betrayal
in a democracy power is ultimately
supposed to rest in the hands of the
people but it doesn't always work that
way lobbying greed and Corruption strip
voters of their power selling influence
to the highest
bidder no one knows this better than
former lobbyist Jack Abron great to see
him thanks so thank you got a table back
here okay from our first hearing Mr
aboff's insatiable greed came to the
four one of K Street's most successful
lobbyists Jack became Infamous when he
was convicted of taking illegal
Kickbacks wire fraud tax evasion and
bribery he spent nearly 4 years in jail
for his crimes some races were impacted
by lawmakers connections to disgraced
lobbyist Jack abramof part of what
Democrats labeled a culture of
corruption okay people go to Washington
first thing they start saying when
they're campaigning is I can't be bought
I'm there to represent you right and it
doesn't last that long no I think almost
everyone shows up like that but over
time and sometimes it's only a few hours
and sometimes it takes a few years
eventually The Lure of the political
money which they need to get reelected
becomes so strong that in fact they get
affected so what happened with you you
were obviously very good at it well I
was deep in the game I opened up a
couple restaurants where I let them eat
like it was a cafeteria when they wanted
to go play golf I would put him on my
airplane and fly him to St Andrews to
play of the old course and uh ultimately
what happened was an article got written
in the Washington post about my lobing
practice on the front page and I became
the Great London Washington and I at
first didn't think I did anything wrong
but I decided to go back and reread the
million emails that I had sent in the
course of being a lobbyist and I started
rethinking myself and started thinking
you know what I cooperated I plad guilty
and away I
went at the end of it I realized it was
wrong this system where people pay to
play in
Washington paying to influence
government is all too common for the
powerful corporations that can afford it
it's estimated that they spend over $9
billion lobbying our elected officials
every year see there with about
535 people between house and the Senate
how many of them are clean well clean in
the sense of not allowing people to give
them money very few maybe a dozen on
both houses maybe maybe but most of them
unfortunately do and they excuse it by
saying this is the system we live in and
this is how things are done this is not
the way a democracy should work no and
it wasn't the way this country was
supposed to
work what should we be doing to make
things a little easier a little
better if the money were removed it
would have an immense effect not only on
the system in terms of our political
system but on the individual Congressman
there are other things also for example
term limits uh I was against term limits
when I was a lobbyist I wanted every
Congressman to die in office when
they're 150 years old cuz the same way
when you have a car right you have a car
you run out of gas you don't go get a
new car you go to the gas station and
put some gas in right yeah so if you've
bought a congressman and you're a
lobbyist you don't want to have to go
buy a new Congressman you just want to
put a little more gas in the tank and
people when they get there at the
beginning they're not really corrupt
they're not part of the system get them
out of there before they become
corrupt well I'm going to tell you
something I'm glad you went to prison
because you had time to think and now
you on a great Cru say you're on the
high road thank
you money is
power so many people in this country
feel they don't have a voice that the
government isn't listening to them that
their vote doesn't
count and that's the
truth as Jack knows all too well you
have to pay to play and our American
political
system I believe if we're going to make
our democracy work if we're going to
make it truly
representational we're going to have to
take money out of the
equation and put people back
in but a seismic shift in the balance of
power is already
underway the explosion of social media
means everyone can express their will
24/7 will technology make leaders more
accountable or will it make leaders
obsolete corruption
repression and
tyranny all rob people of their rights
in
society but the internet has given them
a new way to be heard when When leaders
monopolize power can technology help
people take it back to find out I'm
headed to San
Francisco I'm here to meet one of the
founders of Twitter Evan Williams he's
moved on from Twitter now and created a
new internet startup
medium I'm always curious about if
you'll pardon the expression people like
you m where do you come from who are you
how did you get into this I grew up on a
farm in Nebraska rural Nebraska
literally in the middle of the corn
fields I was uh pretty isolated growing
up and this was pre- internet I had a
computer I learned programming when I
was in high school and when the internet
started emerging in the late '90s what I
believed at the time was once everybody
had a voice we would all be smarter
because good ideas would rise to the top
and truth would rise to the top and we'd
be able to say well that's wrong this is
good let's talk about it I'm thinking
about my father was a barber and the
barber shop was Town Hall mhm so
everybody even heard on the radio or
they read the paper and they came to the
barber shop and discussed
it is Twitter the extension of that yeah
we've we've used that analogy before of
the global town hall turned out it was
more complicated than that so when we
built Twitter it was with the ethos of
we want to connect as many people as
possible and let information flow as
freely as possible and with an
assumption that most people are going to
use that in a good way which is true but
the degree to which people who are The
Bad actors can spoil it for other people
we didn't really design in well enough
and so I compare it to the real world
and saying even if you believe most
people are good people you still May
lock your door when you leave your
house so the internet is a good thing we
can all know more about each other and
perhaps be smarter that's the Hope on
the other hand we have the dark side M
which side's winning it's really pretty
equal match right
now I think what we found is that what
gets rewarded on the internet is
attention it doesn't reward quality of
attention it doesn't reward accuracy of
facts and people have figured out oh
what's the cheapest way to drive
attention have a car
crash and it gets this self-reinforcing
cycle so if you look at a car crash then
the internet thinks oh you like car
crashes here's more car crashes Evan
sees these digital car crashes clickbait
trolls and fake news as threats to the
internet promise of giving power back to
the people have you come up with any
idea about how to go about this I'm
going to call it cleanup the way that I
now think about the internet is it's
neither good nor bad the technology that
makes it easier for people to get what
they
want it's not that dissimilar from other
Technologies if you think about
agricultural
technology help people get what they
want and need nourishment and food with
less effort but then the technology kept
going and it feels like probably gone
too far the fact that we have access to
these cheap calories at all
times and that feels good in the moment
but is Way Beyond
nourishment what are you doing with your
new company to change what people get
from the internet with medium we're
definitely trying to move things in the
right direction we're trying to create a
space for for nuance and depth I think
that's the nourishment that may not be
there in the junk food and we're trying
to make that really
work if we can get to the point where
internet forums and social media truly
reward thoughtful engagement a new form
of democracy could
emerge we could all vote all the time on
every law Representatives could become
obsolete but Evan believes direct
democracy is strong with danger what
we're seeing today is the ability for
everybody to at least have a say and
it's in many instances been phenomenally
powerful online activism has been
incredible but it goes both
ways the alt-right movement which was
really powered by people getting
together online who may have Fringe
ideas in their local community but they
find someone who agrees with them and
collectively they get critical
mass has been pretty scary as well so
the idea of direct democracy today you
know 10 years ago I would have said well
that's going to be awesome because the
right things will happen and now I don't
know so is there hope for direct
democracy in the future I think today's
information environment
underscores the importance of
representative democracy things are so
complex today much more than they were
200 years ago that the idea of let's all
vote on the healthcare Bill and like the
complexity of that to understand it we
need to elect people who who we trust to
make those decisions for us but if
everyone can vote on the laws themselves
you can't stop me from voting just by
gerer mandering my district MH I think
what we're unhappy with is the
representatives not necessarily the
representative democracy but what I
think the internet will drive us toward
is demanding more transparency from the
representatives and being actually
responsive to their constituents needs
and I think it's more possible to make
that happen
now Evan Williams believes that the
internet like the printing press the
radio and television before it is
fundamentally changing the relationship
between we the people and our leaders it
gives us direct and instant contact with
government it has the potential to rest
back power from leaders who have gone
off course but it could also take
democracy in a frightening Direction
steered by hateful hackers vengeful
trolls the task ahead of us now is
learning how to use our new
power
wisely since the dawn of
civilization there's been a tug of war
between society and its
leaders now we need leaders to get
things done but if we give up too much
power tyranny
ensues people lose their right to choose
their own destiny
today we stand at a
Crossroads technology has given billions
of us the power to make our voices heard
louder and clearer than
ever today we have the power to shape
society and be accountable for the world
we
make now I'm hopeful in spite of the
dangers that lie
ahead because I believe that But
ultimately there is one power that is
greater than any
desperate the power of the human
spirit I believe
[Music]
that